[Music]
[Applause]
alright this of course is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show so far many challengers but not
one winner
you'd think they'd stop trying yeah we
don't make mistake it's incredible well
tonight a fan named Aaron thinks that he
has caught a mistake he says it happened
during a recent bit called NBA mascots
who should never dunk hey Conan on last
Thursday show you did a NBA slam dunk
skit which contained a Netflix envelope
contestant
it's the Netflix envelope containing an
unwatched copy of The Tree of Life 3
years ago I made a Netflix envelope
costume for a Halloween party and I hate
to tell you this man but your envelope
design is incorrect as you can see your
envelope says open here along the side
which it should say open along edge you
also do not have a white border around
the outside of your envelope just to
make sure that I was correct
I called Netflix yeah Rhonda my name is
Darren and this is kind of a weird
question I was wondering if you were
able to tell me if the actual envelope
design had changed or not okay that
would be great if you could do that okay
that is all I needed to know thank you
very much so as you can see I'm right
and you're wrong
so I triple dog dare you to get out of
this one
[Music]
triple dog dare no one said that since
1940 pretty big talk for a guy with a
lot of time on it well sorry Darren but
our costume was correct yours is wrong
you say Rhonda told you otherwise over
the phone well guess what
Rhonda lied to you here's the real
authority Netflix CEO Reed Hastings to
explain a message from Netflix president
and CEO Reed Hastings in order to better
serve you the customer our employees go
through a rigorous training process for
instance whenever they get a call from a
crazy person rambling on about the
design of the Netflix envelope our
representatives are trained to go along
with whatever the lunatic says and to
get them off the phone as soon as
possible placating mental patients like
Darren it's all just part of the Netflix
promise that was a message from Netflix
president and CEO Reed Hastings
screw you down
[Music]
once again we win so the challenge still
stands if you think you spotted an error
on our show reported at team koco.com
slash haha I found an error we will sort
it out right here on the air let's see
if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro